se cumplió el peor de los pronósticos en
cuba un tercer tanque de combustible se
incendió en el puerto de matanzas en el
occidente de la isla esto luego que el
viernes un rayo incendio era un primer
tanque del que es el mayor depósito de
combustible de cuba el incendio cambia
en el segundo tanque con un momento
entonces el que es el tanque que ahora
está incendiado de la manera que se
había visto anteriormente funcionando
como un lente ahora homófobo el domingo
en la noche un segundo tanque se vio
también envuelto en llamas ahora los
vertidos de esta nueva explosión ha
reavivado el fuego de los dos depósitos
anteriores está la situación cambiados
es muy complejo
tres tanques encendidos porque además el
bloque de combustible
funciona entonces también como otro otro
forma que está ahí en de grandes
dimensiones puesto este incendio ahonda
en un problema de escasez de combustible
que vive cuba el gobernador de la región
y el propio presidente miguel díaz canel
reconocen que supondrá un problema a
largo plazo lo que hay que seguir
comprando y dedicándole en poco
financiamiento que tenemos para
garantizar a nuestro pueblo la la mínima
energía que eso sea un problema que
tenemos y que como se dijo por nuestro
presidente no a corto plazo a las
labores de extinción se sumaron el
domingo efectivos llegados desde méxico
y venezuela por el momento el incendio
se ha cobrado la vida de un bombero y ha
dejado al menos 16 desaparecidos y 125
heridos todo ello en medio de un déficit
energético que organismos oficiales
cifran en un 35 por ciento para este
lunes